This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是由真人制作。2%。这就是有扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身以及建立适应力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些磨难，从另一端走出来时，你会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。即数字TWO。可在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》播客。相信我，宝贝。可在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾过去》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难学习法》。这个空间关乎黑人群体的体验，进行那些在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习法》。
This is Open Mind. Welcome to a brand new week. Here is your mantra. I embrace growth and change. I'm your host, Gemma Spag, and I'm here to guide you towards a more centered and fulfilling life. Each week, I'll share personal stories. and insights that are focused on a specific mantra, plus journal prompts and a weekly challenge for all of us to help put it into action. Think of mantra as your mental reset button,
这里是《开放思维》。欢迎来到全新的一周。这是你的座右铭。我拥抱成长与改变。我是你的主持人杰玛·斯帕格，我在这里引导你走向一个更加内心平静、生活充实的人生。每周，我都将分享个人故事和深刻见解，这些内容都聚焦于一个特定的座右铭，外加手记提示和每周挑战，帮助我们所有人将其付诸实践。把座右铭想象成你的心理重置按钮，
a way to stay centered as you juggle work, school, family, and whatever else life throws at you. Each mantra is a simple, powerful phrase you can repeat to focus your thoughts and bring a bit of calm into your day. It's a small tool with a big impact. clearing your mind, lifting your mood, and rooting you in the present. If you've listened to my other show, The Psychology of Your 20s, you'll know that I'm all about those little nuggets of insight that make a big impact. So whether you're looking for some extra inspiration or you're trying to ground yourself amidst the chaos, you have come to the right place.
一种在你要兼顾工作、学校、家庭以及生活抛给你的其他任何事情时保持内心平静的方式。每个座右铭都是一个简单而有力的短语，你可以重复它来集中你的思绪，给你的生活带来一丝平静。这是一个影响深远的小工具。它能理清你的思绪，提升你的情绪，并将你扎根于当下。如果你听过我的另一个节目《你二十岁的心理学》，你就会知道我最喜欢那些能产生巨大影响的微小洞察碎片。所以，无论你是想寻找一些额外的灵感，还是想在混乱中试图让自己脚踏实地，你都来对地方了。
At Open Mind, we value your support. Share your thoughts on social media. And remember to rate, review and follow mantra to help others. discover the show. For more exclusive content, monthly bonus episodes, early access, and at free listening, join our Open Mind Plus community on Apple Podcasts. This week, I'll catch you up on what's been going on in my life and then we'll dive into today's mantra. I embrace growth and change. Whether you're facing a big shift or you're just looking to level up your day to day, this mantra is all about helping you grow. Stick around and we'll be right back after this short pause.
在《开放思维》节目中，我们珍视你的支持。请在社交媒体上分享你的想法。并记得给“座右铭”评分、评论和关注，以帮助其他人发现这个节目。如需更多独家内容、每月额外单集、抢先收听以及无广告收听，请在苹果播客上加入我们的“开放思维加”社区。本周，我将向你更新我最近的生活状况，然后我们将深入探讨今天的座右铭。我拥抱成长与改变。无论你是在面对一个重大的转变，还是只是在寻找提升日常生活的方法，这个座右铭的全部意义都在于帮助你成长。请留下来，在短暂的暂停之后我们马上回来。
Welcome back. We're going to get into this week's mantra in just a minute, but before we do, I want to fill you in on what's been going on with me lately and how this mantra has been showing up in my life. I have been contemplating some pretty major life shifts as of late, the kind that I think really makes you pause and wonder what's next and not necessarily know what the right answer is. The biggest question on my mind is whether it's time to pack up and move, maybe not just to a new city, but possibly a whole new country. I feel like we all reach a point like this, a crossroads where we feel comfortable, settled even with where we are. We're very keen to put down roots, but there's this pull towards something that's bigger, something more exciting, and yes, as well, something that might
欢迎回来。我们将在几分钟内探讨本周的座右铭，但在那之前，我想向你透露一下我最近的情况，以及这个座右铭是如何体现在我的生活中的。最近我一直在思考一些相当重大的生活转变，那种我认为真的会让你停下来思考接下来会发生什么，却不一定知道正确答案是什么的转变。我脑海中最主要的问题是，现在是否是时候打包行李搬家了，也许不仅仅是搬到一个新城市，甚至可能是一个全新的国家。我觉得我们都会到达这样一个时刻，一个十字路口，我们在目前的地方感到舒适，甚至是安稳。我们非常热衷于扎根，但有一种吸引力把我们拉向更宏大、更激动人心的事物，当然，也有某种可能会
feel kind of scary. For me, that pool has been Europe. I know it might sound a little bit strange. Australia is beautiful. It's the lucky country. I love it here. It's so serene and calm. But sometimes it feels like there's not enough happening. And as I continue to grow as a person, I'm feeling ready for a big change, ready to meet new people, ready to dive into new cultures, maybe like experience life from a fresh perspective. It's that classic push and pull. Part of me is rooted here and another part feels drawn to something that might challenge me in ways that my life currently doesn't. I can feel myself moving towards a new life chapter and my old life isn't feeling as fulfilling as it once did, but I'm kind of stuck in this waiting room. I'll talk about this a little bit more. Later
让人感到有点害怕的事物。对我来说，这种吸引力就是欧洲。我知道这听起来可能有点奇怪。澳大利亚很美。这是一块幸运的土地。我很喜欢这里。它是如此宁静和平和。但有时感觉这里发生的事情不够多。随着我作为一个人不断成长，我感到自己已经准备好迎接巨大的改变，准备好结识新朋友，准备好融入新文化，也许就像以全新的视角体验生活。这就是经典的推拉效应。我的一部分根植于此，而另一部分则被某种可能以我目前生活没有的方式挑战我的事物所吸引。我能感觉到自己正在走向生活的新篇章，而我旧的生活已经不像以前那样让人感到充实，但我有点卡在这个候诊室里了。我会在稍后更多地谈论这一点。
on in this episode and I'm definitely going to keep you up to date on how these feelings progress in the coming months, but I wanted to give you a little insight as to why I chose this mantra today. So look, this week's guiding phrase is definitely not for the faint of heart. Anyone who has ever encountered change. Even the smallest kind knows that often everything in us cries out for things to stay the same. It is a very human instinct to be safe in what is comfortable. But this mantra forces us to confront a truth that our lives are always evolving, whether we're ready for them to do so or not. Growth doesn't feel as intimidating is change in my mind. We're constantly moving through new experiences, some good, some bad, others just neutral.
在本集的晚些时候，我绝对会随时向你通报这些感受在未来几个月是如何发展的，但我只想让你对为什么我今天选择这个座右铭有一点深入的了解。所以听着，本周的指导短语绝对不适合胆小的人。任何经历过改变的人。即使是最小的改变，也知道我们内心深处的每一种声音都在呼喊着让事情保持原样。在舒适的环境中保持安全是非常人类的本能。但这个座右铭迫使我们面对这样一个事实：我们的生活总是在不断演变，无论我们是否准备好这样做。在我看来，成长似乎不像改变那么令人生畏。我们不断经历新的体验，有些是好的，有些是坏的，还有一些只是中性的。
But each one helps shape who we are and who we're becoming. That is growth. Change, on the other hand, feels more unsettling in comparison to growth because it doesn't carry the same component of positive natural progress that we usually associate with growth periods. Especially in our 20s and our 30s, the idea of change can be really overwhelming because we've spent so much time trying to get things to a stable point. But here's the thing, growth and change, they aren't just inevitable. they're also essential. They're often what pushes us towards becoming our best selves.
但每一项都有助于塑造我们是谁以及我们将要成为谁。这就是成长。相比之下，改变感觉更让人心神不宁，因为它不具备我们通常与成长时期联系在一起的那种积极的自然进展成分。特别是在我们的二十几岁和三十几岁时，改变的想法可能会让人不知所措，因为我们花了太多时间试图让事情达到稳定的状态。但关键在于，成长和改变，它们不仅是不可避免的。它们也是至关重要的。它们通常是将我们推向成为最好的自己的动力。
They move us closer to the lives that we are meant to live, that we deserve to live. At its core, this phrase encourages us to go with life's flow, to choose to lean into change rather than resisting it, knowing that something ultimately quite positive, if not just different, can come from that experience. Embracing growth also means stepping beyond the comfort zone, trying new things and learning along the way. There is nothing more human in my mind than making mistakes, especially when those mistakes expand our understanding of who we are. This phrase is really here to remind us that uncomfortable moments aren't obstacles,
它们使我们更接近我们注定要过、我们理应去过的生活。其核心是，这个顺应生活的潮流，选择顺应改变而不是抗拒它，知道最终会有非常积极的、即使只是不同的结果从这种经历中产生。拥抱成长也意味着走出舒适区，尝试新事物并在沿途学习。在我看来，没有什么比犯错更具人性的了，尤其是当这些错误扩大了我们对自己的理解时。这个短语真的是在提醒我们，不舒服的时刻不是障碍，
their opportunities, and that's the key word here, opportunities. In my experience and from what I'm seeing right now, it honestly feels like everything around us is really evolving at lightning speed. Every day we are presented with new trends, new ideas, new technologies. There's always some new big idea to wrap our minds around and it can present as something that's going to challenge us. That constant evolution is going to perhaps make our lives feel unstable. An example of this that I was thinking about the other day was the invention and spread of AI technology and how many of us feel uncomfortable with it. There's this fear of what that's going to do to our jobs, our way of interacting with one another
而是机遇，这里的关键词是，机遇。根据我的经验以及我目前所看到的，老实说，感觉我们周围的一切都在以光速发展。每天我们都会接触到新的趋势、新的思想、新的技术。总有一些新的宏大理念需要我们去理解，它可能会表现为某种将要挑战我们的事物。这种持续的演变也许会让我们的生活感到不稳定。我前几天想到这方面的一个例子是人工智能技术的发明和传播，以及我们中有多少人对此感到不舒服。人们担心这会对我们的工作、我们的互动方式产生什么影响
and our way of interacting with the world. That is an example of change that feels rapidly quite uncomfortable. And it's definitely a big picture example. But when you think about it on a more micro scale, in terms of your own life, something may be changing in your family with your relationships, in your career, even your living situation maybe, whether it's a breakup or you're moving in with someone, there's a new friendship or a broken one, life keeps presenting opportunities to grow that are hidden in these moments, even when they are challenging. I guess what I'm trying to say
以及我们与世界互动的方式。这是一个感觉相当迅速且令人不舒服的改变的例子。这绝对是一个宏观层面的例子。但当你从微观层面去思考，就你自己的生活而言，某些事情可能正在你的家庭中、你的关系中、你的职业生涯中、甚至你的居住环境中发生改变，无论是分手还是你正与某人同居，一段新的友谊或是一段破碎的友谊，生活不断在这些时刻中隐藏着成长的机遇，即使它们充满挑战。我想我要说的是
is that embracing growth and change is key. We need to stay flexible and resilient. my favorite word here is resilience, because when we are resilient, we understand that no matter what is coming into our life that feels unexpected, we can kind of see it in two ways. We can see it as something that is going to threaten us, or we can see it as an opportunity, instead of holding on to what is familiar just because it feels safe. I think about this especially in terms of relationships. Maybe it's with an ex, a friend, a former colleague, someone that you're just not as close to anymore who maybe doesn't make you feel great about yourself. You can hold on to that good but
拥抱成长与改变是关键。我们需要保持灵活性和韧性。我这里最喜欢的词是韧性，因为当我们拥有韧性时，我们就会明白，无论什么让我们感到意外的事情进入我们的生活，我们基本上可以用两种方式看待它。我们可以把它视为某种将要威胁我们的事物，或者我们可以把它视为一个机遇，而不是仅仅因为感到安全而紧抓着熟悉的事物不放。我尤其在人际关系方面思考这一点。也许是和前任、朋友、前同事，某个你不再那么亲密的人，也许他不会让你对自己感觉很好。你可以坚持那段美好的但
not great relationship because it's always been convenient because it's been something that you've known for a really long time and because your brain has made you feel safe and secure and comfortable in that emotional environment. But you could also move beyond that relationship. You could realize that you deserve great and that there is going to be some pain, some temporary discomfort, but these new experiences and the opportunities that you get from making space for someone new is worth so much more. And I think this mindset changes the way that we deal with life, being able to pivot, be resilient, be flexible when things shift. It doesn't just make you stronger mentally, emotionally, socially. It also makes you happier as well. So let's talk about what all
并非绝佳的关系，因为它一直都很方便，因为它一直是你非常熟悉的事物，并且因为你的大脑让你在这种情感环境中感到安全、安心和舒适。但你也可以超越这段关系。你可以意识到你值得拥有更美好的事物，并且会有一些痛苦，一些暂时的不适，但是这些新的体验以及你通过为新人腾出空间而获得的机遇要宝贵得多。我认为这种心态改变了我们处理生活的方式，能够在事情发生变化时灵活应变、保持韧性和灵活性。它不仅能让你的精神、情绪和社会交往变得更强大。它也会让你更快乐。所以让我们来谈谈这一切
this means for us. And let's start with the emotional discomfort of change. One way that we can really adopt this mantra is by thinking about our best, most ideal self. The person we want to be in the long term, someone who perhaps has their dream life, has moved to a place of abundance, who is more authentic, who is more confident. Really imagine that person for a moment. Imagine that person, Imagine that person that you're going to be in five years, in 10 years. What are they doing? What does their day look like? What are they wearing?
对我们意味着什么。让我们从改变带来的情感不适开始。我们真正采纳这个座右铭的一种方法是思考我们最好、最理想的自我。那个我们在长期内想要成为的人，那个可能拥有理想生活、已经搬到一个丰盛的地方、更加真实、更加自信的人。请真正想象一下那个时刻的那个人。想象那个人，想象你将在五年、十年后成为的那个人。他们在做什么？他们的一天是怎样的？他们穿什么衣服？
What are the obstacles that they're now facing that they can handle even better because of what you're going through now? Is that person going to be realized without change? Probably not. Is that person going to come into existence without growth? No, definitely not. Because if that person was already to exist, you wouldn't be thinking about these things, because it would already be in place. When adopting this week's mantra, I embrace growth and change.
他们现在面临的障碍是什么，由于你现在正在经历的一切，他们能把这些障碍处理得更好？没有改变，那个人能够实现吗？可能不会。没有成长，那个人能够存在吗？不，绝对不会。因为如果那个人已经存在了，你就不会考虑这些事情了，因为它已经到位了。在采纳本周的座右铭“我拥抱成长与改变”时，
I want you to really think about how it's going to take you from where you are now into your future self. Just remember this. This is all about seeing change for what it is. It is not an enemy. It is actually something that helps us, come the best version of ourselves. Coming up, let's get personal. I'm going to get real about how this mantra plays out in my life. The ups, the downs, how I've navigated through it. So stay tuned after this brief pause. Two percent. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there
我希望你真正思考它将如何把你从现在的状态带入未来的自我。只需记住这一点。这一切都是为了看清改变的本质。它不是敌人。它实际上是帮助我们成为最好版本的自己的东西。接下来，让我们变得更私人一些。我将真实地讲述这个座右铭是如何在我的生活中发挥作用的。起起落落，我是如何度过难关的。所以在短暂的暂停后请继续收听。《2%》。这就是有扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身以及建立适应力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，从另一端走出来时，你会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。即数字TWO，可在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, We picky here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
收听《闺蜜》播客。相信我，宝贝。可在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的，和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences. having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难学习法》。这个空间关乎黑人群体的体验。进行那些在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习法》。这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是由真人制作。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。